We haven't talked about this yet, but you do want
plots to speak for themselves. If you look back at some
of the plots we've created, you'll notice that the labels
on the x axis and the y axis are automatically generated.
By default, ggplot2 uses the variable names for the labels.
That's why we can see that tenure divided by 365 appears
right here. We pass that to x, so that's going to
appear in our graph. Now, this might not be the best
label for the x axis, so let's change this. To do
so, we can use the xlab and ylab parameters. Now, making sure
I have a comma after each of these new parameters, I
can run this code and see the labels on their plot. Yeah,
that's a lot better. Now, your x-axis might look slightly different
from mine, and that's because I added scale-x continuous as a layer,
and I made the breaks go from zero to seven. That's
what this bit of code does here. Now, when you conduct EDA,
your plots don't need to be perfect. I
don't want you to stress about formatting, but do
focus on making sensible choices for scales and limits
on each axis. When you return to your plots
and to your code later, labels can function as
comments about what the code was intended to do.
Likewise, if you were to share a plot with
a colleague, labels can make your plots more understandable.